It’s that time of
year when tissue companies nationwide rejoice
at the excessive mucus caused by allergies.
If you’re one of the unlucky, you might
ask yourself why we get them anyway?
Why would our immune systems react to seemingly
harmless things like pollens, dust mites,
and the dander from cats and dogs?
There are two proposed theories here; the
most widely accepted involves an evolutionary
mechanism for expelling parasitic worms, a
frequent problem for our ancestors before
the advent of modern medicine and potentially
living in a more hygienic environment.
A relatively newly suggested competing theory
is that the reaction is due to how the immune
system responds to a type of cell, known as
a mast cell, when it releases its chemicals
of inflammation.
Before we can understand the two theories,
it’s important to know how the immune system
works in general when it encounters a potential
allergen.
There are two ways it can deal with a foreign
pathogen- either kill it (type 1 reaction)
or attempt to expel it from the body (type
2 reaction).
Should you have a large pathogen, like say
a parasitic worm, the body would generally
illicit the type 2, expulsion tactic.
A smaller microbe, like a bacteria or virus,
will generally trigger the type 1 response.
What exactly is happening when the immune
system gets stimulated?
(In an attempt to avoid writing a book on
the topic, I will only touch on the parts
pertaining to allergies themselves and not
the immune system as a whole.)
All the cells of your immune system revolve
around a class of cells called white blood
cells.
One type of white blood cell is a B cell.
B cells have antibodies on their surface;
known as Immunoglobulins (Ig), they are Y
shaped proteins.
When an allergen contacts your skin, eye,
nasal passage, mouth, airway, or in your digestive
tract, it will attach to the antibody on the
B cell.
The B cell will then become activated.
Once activated, they will begin to multiply.
Some turn into memory B cells that will recognize
the same molecule later in life and be able
to more quickly mount a defense.
Some turn into plasma B cells (effector cells).
These make more identical antibodies that
attach to the molecule its predecessor just
recognized.
They’re so good at it that one effector
cell can produce about 2000 identical antibodies
per second!
Those antibodies will then attach to the invader
and mark it for recognition by other white
blood cells that will destroy the suspicious
molecule.
They do this by attaching themselves in a
process called opsonization.
Different allergens will end up producing
different antibodies.
In 1967, two research groups from Colorado
and Sweden identified a new type of Ig, known
as IgE.
This little antibody proved to be the main
force starting a cascade of events that leads
to those sinister allergy symptoms.
More recently, scientist have been able to
genetically engineer mice to stop making IgE.
Those mice don’t get allergies.
Science!
In any event, once produced, IgE begins circulating
around and attaches to the receptors (Fc type
I and II) on the previously mentioned mast
cell.
These cells are responsible for most of the
processes involved in the symptoms you feel
when suffering from allergies.
When stimulated, they begin secreting a barrage
of chemicals, called degranulation.
One example is the release of histamine.
Histamine is important for several of our
allergic reaction symptoms- things like the
constriction of your bronchioles, the dilation
of your arteries, the perception of itching,
and the production of hives.
It’s also responsible for many of the processes
involved with inflammation.
So to sum up on the how, or at least as it’s
generally understood (there is some controversy
here as we’ll get into in a moment) an allergen
enters the body, attaches to B cells; IgE
is created and stimulates mast cell degranulation;
inflammation ensues and all the symptoms you
feel begin causing their web of woe.
The immune system stays activated until it
senses no more allergen to attack, and you’re
now you’re back to normal!
With the “how” covered, this bring us
back to the question of why we get allergies
to things that are seemingly harmless?
No one has definitively answered the question,
but everyone seems to agree that IgE is the
main antibody responsible for all the immune
system reactions and the inflammation it brings.
So, what in natural selection made IgE an
important trait required for our ancestor’s
survival given today some consider it mostly
useless, and more than a little annoying for
those with allergies?
Until recently, the leading theory revolved
around parasitic worms.
In 1964, scientist Bridget Ogilvie showed
that IgE was found to be in abundance in rats
infected with worms.
Our ancestors also had a problem with worms.
They didn’t have access to modern medicine
and hygienic environments that have reduced
the infection rate down to the current 20%
worldwide (with most that are infected residing
in underdeveloped countries).
Throughout much of history, everything from
roundworms, such as hook-worms, to flatworms,
like tapeworms and liver flukes, were relatively
common.
IgE and the symptoms it creates, like sneezing
coughing and diarrhea, all serve to expel
those nasty little freeloaders.
As Dr. David Dunne from the university of
Cambridge states, “You’ve got about an
hour to react very dramatically in order to
reduce the chance of these parasites surviving…
Allergy is just an unfortunate side-effect
of defense against parasitic worms.”
So IgE’s ability to kick things into high
gear to quickly react to such an invader would
seemingly be very handy here.
What do parasitic worms have to do with allergies?
The idea here is that the reason we get such
a strong reaction to certain other less threatening
things that our immune system might be much
better off ignoring is that the proteins on
the surface of parasitic worms are similar
to the molecules we encounter in other aspects
of our lives.
The B cells responsible for the immediate
immune system response react to a non-specific
class of molecules.
Thus, our immune system will respond to allergens
that are structurally similar to the proteins
found on the surface of worms.
The body then attempts to rid itself of them,
whether they’re harmful or not.
The left-over response from our immune system
reacting to worms (and now similar protein
molecules) is why allergies continue to torment
landscapers everywhere, or at least as far
as this theory goes.
While a long-standing theory and very widely
accepted in the medical world, the defense
against worm’s philosophy gets somewhat
undermined when you look at studies showing
IgE isn’t actually strictly necessary to
fight them off.
The mice scientists have genetically engineered
to be unable to produce IgE are still able
to rid themselves of the parasites.
That’s not to mention the fact that people
can have these types of allergic reactions
to things that have no possible biological
link to any protein found on a worm, such
as reacting to the metal nickle.
So even if this is a factor in why we have
allergic responses to seemingly otherwise
harmless things, it can’t tell the whole
story.
This brings us to the slightly newer theory
as to why we have allergies.
It also involves the idea of our bodies attempting
to expel allergens, but instead of the immune
system recognizing a structurally similar
protein molecule to that on parasitic worms
and misinterpreting that the body has acquired
such a parasite, it is the immune system reacting
to actual damage caused by that invader- namely,
the destruction of those mast cells.
When mast cells begins to degranulate, the
body begins making antibodies to several of
the proteins around the area affected to try
to get rid of whatever foreign agent.
Should it inadvertently make an antibody to,
for instance, the proteins found on peanuts,
you will then get memory B cells to fight
against peanut molecules in future.
Congratulations, you now potentially have
a peanut allergy.
Dr. Ruslan Medzhitov, professor of Immunobiology
at Yale University School of Medicine (and
arguably the biggest promoter of this theory),
likes to think of it like how we protect our
homes.
If you’re not home and someone breaks into
your house, your alarm system won’t go off
based on recognizing the intruder’s face,
but by the fact that they broke a window.
So in a nutshell, it’s not recognizing the
molecule, but rather simply creating antibodies
for things around mast cells degranulating.
In support of this theory, Dr. Medzhitov and
co. began investigating potential cell damage
caused by various allergens.
For instance, when they injected mice with
an allergen found in honey-bee venom, PLA2,
they found that their immune systems did not
initially respond at all to the PLA2 itself.
It wasn’t until the PLA2 ripped open cell
membranes that the immune system kicked into
gear producing IgE as a rapid response mechanism.
And, as previously mentioned, other pathogens
in the area might potentially get implicated
as the “house burglar,” with your immune
system creating the memory B cells to react
to it later.
Fascinatingly, no matter which side of the
why-we-get-allergies debate you’re on (or
even if you think both ideas are partially
correct or both incorrect), one thing almost
all researchers agree on is that allergy rates
are increasing.
For instance, nearly 30% of adults and 40%
of children in the US are affected by some
sort of allergy.
Why?
We’ve known for a long time that both genetics
and the environment play a part in getting
allergies.
Technology has also allowed us to create countless
never-before-seen synthetic chemicals.
Their associated molecules could potentially
trigger any number of reactions by the immune
system that our ancestors didn’t have to
worry about, perhaps being one factor in the
increased allergy rates.
Another potential factor is something known
as the hygiene hypothesis.
Many scientists believe that with the promotion
of good hygiene taught throughout the industrialized
world, which most definitely does have an
amazing number of significant benefits, there
may also be a downside in that children aren’t
being exposed to as many pathogens that their
immune systems can learn to respond to correctly,
or some even postulate potentially need to
respond to develop the immune system properly.
The idea in the latter case is that for most
of human evolution, the immune system developed
being exposed to these pathogens as a matter
of course, and, similar to how we’ve evolved
to need many types of microbes in the digestive
system to survive, the idea goes that the
human immune system perhaps has evolved to
need to be exposed to certain things in order
that it later correctly responds to introduced
pathogens, rather than triggering an allergic
response to things it might be better off
ignoring.
Thus the immune system later in life overreacts
to some things, or sometimes even reacts to
parts of the body itself.
Potential supporting evidence put forth in
support of this idea is the similar massive
rise in not only allergy rates, but of various
auto-immune diseases.
In both cases, there hasn’t been a corresponding
rise in allergy and auto-immune disease rates
in individuals from underdeveloped countries
who get exposed to various pathogens more
similar to our ancestors throughout history.
On the flipside, children who live in urban
environments, and particularly those without
siblings, have the highest allergy rates of
all.
(Of course, that extra exposure to pathogens
comes with a cost in things like higher childhood
mortality rates from said exposure and the
like.
So even if the hygiene hypothesis is correct,
it would appear there’s something of a trade-off
happening here.)
As is now presumably abundantly clear, no
matter how we get allergies, the why is unfortunately
still the topic of hot debate with little
in the way of concrete answers currently available.
But whether you subscribe to the “recognition”
worm theory or the “alarm system” protecting
your house theory, rest assured that IgE,
once thought to be mostly useless outside
of its aid in expelling parasitic worms but
now thought by some to play a significant
beneficial role in early recognition and reaction
to various pathogens, is the molecule responsible
for all
the madness.
Along the lines of the idea that the immune
system needs to be exposed to certain things
to properly develop, one proposed treatment
for certain allergies and auto-immune disorders
is simply introducing parasitic worms to the
body, known as helminthic therapy.
This therapy (usually) uses worms that have
limited negative long term impact on the human
body and in some cases ones that will be naturally
expelled in due course.
While research in this area is still very
much in the preliminary stages, the early
results in some cases have been promising
enough to warrant continued research.
For instance, as noted in one survey paper
on the subject, “In initial safety studies
patients with Ulcerative colitis (UC) or Crohn’s
disease were given viable, embryonated T.suis
eggs (TSO) and not only was the treatment
well tolerated but a significant disease remission
was observed and although the beneficial effect
was temporary, repeated doses of TSO sustained
this clinical improvement suggesting a promising
new therapy for IBD…”
However, it goes on to note that after many
other studies looking at this therapy for
various immune conditions, “…most of the
experimental data available suggest that once
the allergic reaction is established, helminth
infections can do little to alter this, raising
the inevitable question whether there is any
true benefit to gain from helminth therapy
in already allergic individuals.”